foreign
we're actually going to start with our
main story tonight which concerns Ron
DeSantis business Fred Flintstone
DeSantis has been all over the news this
week as he is seemingly every week he
appointed his political backers to a new
Disney oversight board he released a new
book the courage to be free and by the
way I have a little gift for our studio
audience look under your seats the gift
is it isn't there you don't have
you're welcome and he also put out this
eye-catching video
Florida is proof positive that we the
people are not destined for failure the
Santa's wins he has made a promise and
he's making good on the promise Florida
is leading the nation decline is a
choice
Seth is
and freedom is worth fighting for
wow there is a lot there but Florida's
proof that we the people are not
destined for failure I don't know about
that Ron last year alone in Florida a
man tried to steal a crossbow by
stuffing it down his pants a woman
instigated a police chase so she could
cross getting arrested off her bucket
list and a man was charged with battery
for throwing a hot dog at a police
officer we the people may not be
destined for failure but a lot of
individuals down there sure do seem
drawn to it
this all feels like part of a
coordinated rollout of desantis's
inevitable presidential campaign because
even though he hasn't yet officially
announced he's running he's already made
V's favorite candidate after his
Landslide re-election as Governor last
November the New York Post proclaimed
him the future which is you know
depressing and he received this cringing
juicing introduction from Carrie Lake
I'll tell you what he's got I don't know
if you heard of this but he's got bde
anybody know what that means
ask your kids about it later
big DeSantis energy okay that is
obviously terrible but just to be clear
if you don't know what bde is please
don't ask your kids about it later in
fact for the sake of those kids I'll
just tell you right now it stands for
big dick energy a kind of easy magnetic
confidence that doesn't necessarily mean
you have a large penis or indeed a penis
at all it's just the energy associated a
list of those with bde would include
Brian Cranston Christine Baranski the
Pixar lamp Charles Darwin and Snoopy
does that make sense please come to me
and not your kids if you need any penis
related slang explained in the future
and look it is worth noting in general
you can't predict much about a
presidential race 20 months out previous
early Front Runners includes Jeb Bush
the late Jeb Bush I don't know it's
unclear Howard's Dean and Rudy Julia
only who is currently wandering around
Central Park covered in Thousand Island
dressing and screaming about election
fraud to pigeons
is eventually likely to have to go up
against Donald Trump Which history has
shown is no easy task and while Trump
initially struggled to coin a damaging
nickname for DeSantis with his first
attempt being the embarrassingly weak
Ronda sanctimonious he later unveiled
something with a lot more punch
according to the times Trump has spent
weeks trying to go DeSantis into a fight
describing him in conversations as
meatball Ron yeah
apparently he was calling him meatball
Ron and I hate to say it but Trump's
still got it it's
perfectly stupid childish and hurtful in
a way that's genuinely difficult to
articulate also it's a pretty good name
on its own if you ask me to describe the
perfect meatball Ron I'd say I don't
know maybe a round little hamster or or
this smiley cartoon character you know
little arms and legs little mustache
maybe voiced by Chris Pratt in the
straight to streaming kids movie with
weirdly Christian undertones that feels
vaguely anti-italian somehow but then if
you simply showed me a photo of this guy
I'd say forget everything that I just
said that is my meatball run right there
that is my meatball but whatever Trump
calls him in the future the fact is
meatball Ron remains a strong Contender
for the Republican nomination and while
many commentators insist on framing him
solely in opposition to Trump saying
things like he's Donald Trump with a
brain that doesn't seem particularly
meaningful it's like saying that new
restaurant is better than this chicken
pot pie that fell on the sidewalk sure
it is but you're not really giving me
much useful information there so if I
make quote Tom Brady's publicist while
reviewing his old golf photos let's take
Trump out of the picture and tonight
let's examine DeSantis on his own merits
and and look at just some of what he's
done two and four the over 20 million
people of Florida because it's sometimes
less than he claims sometimes less than
his critics claim and sometimes worse
than you may know and let's skip over
his early life the short version being
he grew up in Florida was a standout
baseball player and even got to the
Little League World Series with his
local team he then went to Yale then
Harvard Law School and subsequently
joined the Navy as an attorney
eventually he married his wife Casey
despite having the most bizarre dating
tactic I have ever heard according to a
former classmate DeSantis would
apparently tell dates he likes Thai food
but pronounced it thigh
and if they corrected him he would make
up an excuse and leave because quote he
didn't want a girlfriend who corrected
him and if that is
wow just imagine being on that date
you're out at dinner and out of nowhere
your date tells you that he really likes
Thai food and you think wait did he just
call Thai food thai food I must have
misheard but then he goes on to say that
he knows a great Thai food restaurant in
the area or while staring very intently
at you almost studying your reaction to
us politely as you can you say wait do
you mean Thai
like from Thailand and then suddenly his
face drops and he says sorry I forgot I
have a doctor's appointment tonight and
he leaves leaving you both with the
check and the single greatest first date
disaster story of all time
flashing forward
in 2012 DeSantis was elected to congress
though while there a former colleague
says that he always had his earbuds in
to keep people away and if you're
picking up on a theme of Rhonda santis
doesn't like hearing anyone's voice but
his own you're on to something because
in Florida Governor he's made shutting
down dissenting voices something of a
feature here is a campaign ad from last
year in which he shows off his skill at
battling the media
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your Governor speaking today's
training Evolution dog fighting taking
on the corporate media number one
don't fire unless fired upon but when
they fire you fire back with
overwhelming force does it say that in
the bill I'm asking you to tell me
what's in the bill number two never ever
back down from a fight if I could
complete the question though so you're
going to give a speech or ask a question
number three don't accept their
narrative it's wrong it's a fake
narrative I just disabused you of the
narrative and you don't care about the
facts amazingly until around 40 seconds
ago top gun Maverick was my favorite
movie off last year but now I'm sad to
say it's my least favorite movie of all
time tied with cats and there's a
brooder film
DeSantis is constantly complaining the
media is taking him out of context
although it is worth noting that in that
ad he's removing some pretty important
context from the media take that clip
where he said are you going to give a
speech or ask a question if you look at
the start of that exchange you'll notice
that only one person is doing the
fighting there Governor what has gone
wrong with the rollout of the vaccine
that we've seen phone lines jammed
websites crashed it's a lot of demand I
mean I think at the end of the day
excuse me excuse me
I just said what has gone wrong so I'm
answering the question if I could
complete the question though so you're
going to give a speech are you going to
answer ask a question without due
respect Governor you asked the question
I'm going to answer it no you're you're
giving a speech you asked the question I
am trying to ask you that you're going
to ask how many questions you get three
they only got one question why do you
get three with all due respect Governor
I'm just asking if I could finish my
question you didn't you finished the
question no she didn't
is some basic accountability when you
see that in context that's a pretty
gross case of someone meatball splaining
to a journalist who's just trying to do
a job though to be clear
DeSantis doesn't hate all media because
there is one notable exception and it's
the exact one that you are thinking of
DeSantis is on Fox News all the time
morning noon and night even by
Republican standards the mutual
affection between him and fox is pretty
extreme in just one four-month stretch
the network asked him to appear on his
Airwaves 113 times or nearly once a day
with one Fox producer even offering to
let him pick the subject matter if he
agreed to come on which is just pathetic
I'll put it this way if Fox News ever
went on a date with Ron DeSantis they
definitely wouldn't correct him when he
called it Thai food
the percentage isn't just another Fox
talking head he sells himself as someone
with a proven track record and he has
done some terrible stuff for instance at
his urging his State's Medical Board
banned gender affirming care for minors
and he signed a 15-week abortion ban
into law while recently suggesting he'd
sign a six-week one if it reached his
desk but look lots of Republican
Governors have done things like that
what makes this santis extra popular on
the right is his willingness to wage big
symbolic culture wars he's bragged that
he's made Florida the freest state in
America while defending its residents
from the greatest scourge of our time
wokism is really a form of cultural
Marxism the wokism is the new religion
of the left we are not and will never
ever surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die okay first
Florida is not where woke goes to die
it's where wealthy Upper East Side New
Yorkers go did I get you fact strikes
but second DeSantis says woke so often
it begins to lose all meaning but if you
wonder what he thinks it actually stands
for his general counsel wants helpfully
defined woke in court as the view that
there are systemic injustices in
American society and they need to have
policies that address them which is a
hell of a thing for someone to admit to
everyone that you are against
DeSantis might really want to invest in
a lawyer more willing to lie for him I
actually understand there's one
currently wandering around Central Park
who is available if you can catch him
but you have to be careful he's slippy
de Santa spends a lot of energy decrying
wokeness and empty virtue signaling
although he also seems to spend a huge
amount of time doing the right wing
version of exactly that for instance
there was the time that he waited on in
on Leah Thomas a trans woman who'd won
an event in an NCAA swimming
Championship the second place finisher
happened to be from Florida which
DeSantis then took as an excuse to come
out and do this
look at what the NCAA has done by
allowing basically men to compete in
women's Athletics in this case the
swimming you had the number one woman
who finished was from Sarasota we're
going to be doing a proclamation uh
saying that Emma is the best female
swimmer in the 500 meter freestyle
because she earned that okay a aside
from being gross and awful to be
very clear DeSantis doesn't have the
power to declare or disqualify winners
in college sports rendering that
Proclamation completely pointless but
since men in suits seem to be using
their platforms to invalidate past
athletic achievements out of pure spite
I hereby declare that by signing this
Ron desantis's Little League team the
soyin meatballs did not in fact ever
make the Little League World Series
instead Houston's Place wasn't
henceforth be taken by the season six
cast of RuPaul's Drag Race I declare it
it is declared it is done
but but it's gone Way Beyond just empty
hateful proclamations DeSantis has also
signed a bunch of attention grabbing
bills that seem designed to Delight
conservatives and enrage liberals and
while the announcements of these bills
tend to get a lot of national media
coverage the actual implementation of
them can get far less scrutiny take to
Santa's so-called anti-riot law which he
passed following the black lives matter
protests in the summer of 2020. that law
among other things strengthens criminal
penalties for those deemed rioters at
demonstrations and he loves to brag to
conservative audiences about just how
mad it's made people and I have to say
brag a little bit our anti-riot
legislation was recently criticized by
the United Nations so I wear that as a
badge of honor okay
but being chastised by the UN isn't
innately positive what other admonitions
would fill DeSantis with a misplaced
sense of Pride I was also criticized by
the Holocaust Museum Lego called me a
scumbag and Malala yousafzai said she
punched me in the throat if you ever got
a chance so I wear that as a badge of
honor
but it is not just the UN that had a
problem with that law a judge issued a
preliminary injunction blocking the key
part of it from being enforced arguing
that it could effectively criminalize
legal protected speech and that it was
vague to the point of
unconstitutionality and the same thing
happened to his stop social media
censorship act which again got a huge
amount of attention when he first signed
it they threatened social media
platforms with fines for Banning
political candidates and he proposed it
shortly after a number of them had
removed Trump in the wake of January 6th
because of you know that thing
but that law is also under a preliminary
injunction from a judge who at one point
told the DeSantis administration's
lawyers I won't put you on the spot and
ask if you've ever dealt with a statute
that was more poorly drafted and look he
is still fighting those lawsuits and
future decisions could wind up going his
way after all these cases are going
through higher courts that range from
Fairly conservative all the way up to
overturned Roe v Wade but even when
DeSantis has existing laws on his side
his application of them can be slap Dash
and gross just last year he made a big
show of announcing his new elections
crime and Security Office had
spearheaded the arrest of 20 people
who'd voted illegally but these were
lastly people who the state had cleared
to join the voter rolls so they assumed
they were eligible to vote despite the
fact that they technically weren't now
one way of dealing with that would have
been to Simply contact those people
explain the mistake and remove them from
the roles but instead what DeSantis
chose to do was to send armed cops to
conduct arrests with body cam video
later revealing police with guns drawn
pulling people out of their houses and
if you listen to the cops involved even
they seem annoyed and embarrassed at
what they're having to do
foreign
commit no fraud well so that's the thing
I don't know exactly what happened with
it but you you do have a warrant that's
what it's for we are doing this now and
this happened years ago I don't know I I
have no idea man wow do you have any
idea how sketchy your order needs to be
for cops to enforce it reluctantly
enforcing laws on scared people is one
of their favorite things to do it's that
make siren go wee-woo
and end off list now now since then
several of those cases including all
those we just showed you have been
dropped or dismissed but it really feels
like desantis's main aim there as in so
many cases was just to instill fear to
make people afraid to protest or to
moderate content or even to vote and
that is the thing even his sloppily
written laws can end up doing real harm
and maybe the clearest place to see all
of this in action is in Florida schools
because he's been very busy there you
probably remember last year's passage of
HB 1557 the Florida parental rights in
Education Act also known as the don't
say gay Bill though DeSantis says that
name pushes a false narrative and has
claimed that the bill simply says no
sexual instruction to kids pre-k through
three but the truth is the bill is not
as narrow as that at all as this
DeSantis supporter openly acknowledges
well this bill is trying to prevent his
indoctrination of our children but the
bill is a sweeping General piece of
legislation that doesn't just apply to
young children it applies throughout the
entire school age where it says
age-appropriate teaching of gender
identity and sexuality so the bill is it
does you're right it targets
kindergarten to third grade and it says
or age appropriate yeah yeah so when is
it age appropriate to talk about uh
homosexuality it varies by the by the
individual you would you would sue a
teacher if they started talking to your
daughter about same-sex marriage or
lgbtq issues at the age of 17. if they
don't have my concern and I think it's
it's not appropriate for my daughter yes
wow yeah
I think a lot of people would be quite
shocked to hear that
well because it's kind of a mainstream
that is that is the law exactly I know
that's rough to hear but he is
technically right there thanks to Ron
DeSantis right now it is the law in
Florida and quick side note it's funny
how it's always the people who think
homosexuality is a concept needs to be
taught at an appropriate age they don't
give a second thought to when they teach
their kids what heterosexuality is
although I could be wrong maybe in that
guy's family his kid asks every day who
are you people living in my house
and he responds well my name is Dad that
lady is Mom and we are we're friends
don't ask me any more questions until
you're 18 or I will sue you and
it is not just sexuality into Santa's
crosshairs he's also passed an act
called the stop woke act which limits
the ways concepts related to systemic
racism and sex discrimination can be
discussed in schools and to hear him
tell it laws like that are badly needed
because the wokeness in schools goes way
deeper than anyone might think I will
have math books sent to my department of
education for a review these textbooks
and they will do things like woke math
and I'm thinking to myself two plus two
equals four it's not two plus two well
let's have a struggle session over that
how do you feel about it no no no
there's a right answer here I mean out
of context he's completely right there
numbers don't have feelings if they did
this one would be sad this one would be
giggly and this one will be exciting for
a few minutes but then the novelty wears
off and it mostly just gets tired and
sore the same Atlantis has claimed that
his state had to reject math books for
containing indoctrinating Concepts like
race essentialism especially bizarrely
for elementary school students now that
is a big claim and if it sounds like
to you that's because it
absolutely is reporters for these
Outlets come from thousands of pages of
Elementary School textbooks and their
reviews and couldn't find any such
examples and when the dissensitive
administration eventually produced just
four tiny Snippets of what they claimed
was objectionable material for the two
that came from grade school books there
is nothing about race although one does
suggest students practice with
empathizing with classmates while they
fulfill a lesson objective of
identifying numbers from one to five in
sequence that is it so his big claim of
woke math and race essentialism in grade
schools is basically regular math and
trying to teach kids not to be dicks to
each other a kind of math education that
descents himself frankly might have
benefited from us his solution to
figuring out the difference between one
and three questions seems to be yell
until the other person stops talking
and the most recent thing you may have
heard about
our books being pulled from shelves in
Florida schools with viral images like
these making the rounds online now in
classic fashion DeSantis has pushed back
on those images hard they've tried to
create in Florida a narrative
um it's basically a book ban hoax it's a
hoax what they're doing and they're
trying to say that because we have
parental rights and because we have
curriculum transparency if you have a
book that has hardcore pornography for
10 in a library that 10 year olds can
access a parent objects to that that
does not satisfy Florida standards it
should not be in the library with those
young kids and I think I think 99 of
parents agree with that okay first let's
debunk the most egregious claim there
because 99 of parents don't agree on
anything I'm pretty sure you can find at
least 10 percent of parents who are
against covering electrical sockets in
reach of toddlers they're called zap
moms and they're all about letting kids
discover their own limits of electricity
but I will give to Santa's this there
has been some misinformation floating
around online this viral list of books
that were supposedly banned Statewide in
Florida circulated widely but it's
nonsense having said that those images
of empty shelves are very real and are
the direct result of desantis's actions
because he signed legislation mandating
the only approved books could be
included in any school or classroom
library and that approval must come from
a certified media specialist that led
some districts including the ones those
photos are from to tell teachers to
remove or cover books not because they
were pushing a false narrative but
because they were trying to comply with
this Santa's his stupid law and what
DeSantis might say well this isn't
overreaction because those books will
return once they are approved not all of
them because thanks to his new law as
well as that don't say gay bill and his
stop woke act he has turbocharged the
movement among conservatives to get
books removed from libraries that they
just don't like and this goes Way Beyond
removing hard hardcore pornography or
the usual kind of give and take between
parents and school boards that has been
going on for decades now what does
santis has done is make it so anyone in
a community can challenge these books
reporters track down one woman who
submitted 21 book challenges in one
County only to find that she's a retiree
with no children who fully admits that
she hasn't read all of them but I've
read them in partial so basically she
just skimmed them and said I'm pretty
sure nobody should read this which is
coincidentally exactly how I feel about
Rhonda Santa's new book but I'm not
trying to get it taken out of libraries
am I meanwhile this teacher in Escambia
County Florida challenged around 115
books among them titles like and Tango
makes three a picture book based on the
true story of two male penguins at the
Central Park Zoo who raised a baby chick
together Apparently one of her
objections to it is that a second grader
could read it and the idea would pop
into their mind that these are two
people of the same sex that love each
other and the problem is schools are
acting on those sorts of complaints
there was a recent school board meeting
in that county to address the calls to
ban three of the books on that teacher's
list including the penguin one multiple
community members came to testify in
favor of banning it and some made it
abundantly clear exactly what law they
felt empowered them
I probably wouldn't even talk about this
book except for right and wrong as a
clear line and it's not gray so it is
black and white it's black and white
with the law when we talk about
h-1557 we're talking about
indoctrination
and when you look up this book on
Destiny discover on the schools and
County website
the book says this book is about two
male penguins that fall in love Jesus
said go and sin no more so this this
it's against the law
thank you wow just about the work he had
to put into that that man had to shower
put on a pair of pants decide what shirt
to wear choose the light blue one that's
two sizes too big drive to the meeting
Park his car walk into the building wait
a while for his turn to speak also they
could eventually stand behind a Podium
and say out loud as an adult that he's
mad about gay Penguins you almost have
to admire his dedication to being such a
idiot for the
that idiot one at that meeting
the board voted to ban and Tango makes
three from its schools and when you take
all of this together the book's being
removed the inane proclamations to shame
trans athletes these sloppy attempts to
criminalize protests and you combine it
with everything else from the support
for restrictive abortion bans to the
efforts to stop gender affirming care it
really begins to feel like the freest
state in America is only free to the
extent that anyone wants to behave
exactly the way that Ron DeSantis thinks
they should and look in the months to
come you're going to hear a lot of
DeSantis versus Trump comparisons and
the truth is he'll probably come out
well in a lot of them more or less by
default but that cannot be the bar here
it is important to consider the
scientists in his own right if Donald
Trump never existed and that's just all
pause and enjoy that hypothetical just
for a second
is Donald Trump never existed and you
were forced to learn about Rhonda santis
from scratch with no basis for
comparison what you would see would
justifiably horrify you because you've
been discovering a petty autocrat and a
bully a man with no interest in hearing
dissent questions or indeed the correct
pronunciation of Thai food
and all in all a man who is and I do not
use this term lightly just a
meatball